Brooks koepka joins us from Florida
fresh off winning the PGA Championship
Brooks thanks for joining us if I walked
into your house how long would it take
before I knew what you did for a living
when you looked at the counter the
kitchen counter and it's got those three
trophies on there they're on the kitchen
counter yeah it's we had them set up the
other day and it was it was it makes you
really realize what what I've done it's
pretty cool man it's it's hard to put no
words could you tweet out a picture of
all three on the kitchen counter for us
all right that would be great
you won the PGA Championship because
what I drove the ball really well that
we I felt like I was I was very
confident with the driver even though I
cracked the driver the week before we
got there and cracked it ahead and had
to replace it but I felt good and then
my putting by putting I feel like I made
those keep us those momentum putts to
kind of really take it away especially
on 15 and 16 there at the end I talked
to Nick Faldo on Monday and I asked him
about this driving distance like how far
is is gonna be too far and he says he
thinks maybe 1% more is about as far as
a human can hit a golf ball what do you
think of that comment younger guys I've
seen a couple of these guys coming out
of college and they're bombing it past
me I don't know what's gonna happen
these kids man they just said it so far
and they're leaving me in the dust which
is hard to think of because I've been so
long for the last you know a few years
or longer hitters on tour and these kids
are hitting at 340 no problem I think I
think you kid Cameron champ whoo awesome
driving on the seventh hole drive the
green and we were 67 yards short wait
you make it sound like you're an old man
ready for the Champions Tour you're 28
Brooks these young kids no come on
college man they're good they're ready
to win right away it's impressive to see
it it's cool to watch it's fun golf's
gonna be exciting for the next 20 years
that
I was wondering about this because you
being 28 the last time Tiger won ten
years ago so you're 18 but all of these
younger players and I even said this to
Justin Thomas you guys don't know what
those Tiger roars are really like you've
heard about him but once you're on the
course you can tell when somebody has a
great shot and then you can tell when
Tiger has a great shot you're playing
behind Tiger could you tell the
difference between a regular roar and
then something that Tiger did oh it's so
obvious it's so obvious you get any
anybody else in the field makes a birdie
and you might hear like a little
applause and then it's higher once he
even makes contact you you know you know
what shot he's hidden I mean that's how
loud the people are when they're hidden
and then you know when he stuffs it in
there and makes a birdie putt I mean it
feels like the whole crowd roars and
then when they're putting it up on the
leaderboard you can kind of hear another
roar from three holes ahead and then you
hear another hole when they just changed
the leaderboard I mean just everyone's
cheering for me as I should man he's uh
he's the reason I'm playing he's the
best ever by the game so it's it was fun
to compete with him how cool was that
that he waited for you to congratulate
you
yeah I was surreal it really was you
know to hang around there on 18 I know
he's finished probably about 30 minutes
before but to hang around I wasn't
expecting it it was probably the coolest
gesture he could have done and it was
fun going toe-to-toe with him and and
Adams got the two guys I looked up to my
entire life and to battle it out with
them I mean if you'd told me when I was
12 years old that that would have
happened I would have I mean I would
have been a dream come true you look
like you could play football now I know
you didn't look like that when you first
joined the tour but did you play other
sports growing up I did I played a lot
of baseball I wasn't allowed to play
football apparently I was too small and
basketball I realized I was too short
and that wasn't really going to work out
and so I stuck with baseball and golf
and then kind of made a decision there
just stick with golf but I'm not
that big that's the thing that I'm I'm
about the size of maybe a cornerback pre
safety at this medium shirts yeah who
designs these shirts here because it
just feels like they're a little tighter
than they need to be Brooks yeah I know
we're working on it we're working on
trying to fill it now I know we've
gotten to that point so he might might
have to step into a bigger size here but
it's funny I laugh you know I saw Brian
Urlacher didn't interview the other day
and it was quite funny and he said he
was impressed at how big I wasn't and I
just showed you and you just have to
laugh because I stood next to him and
I'm like my god this guy is massive neck
shoulders traps I mean these guys are
massive and to be compared to them it
makes me laugh all the times that I
might stand next to those guys who play
football and you realize how big they
really are but that's the way it was
when I first met Jack Nicklaus he's the
golden bear and then I met him and I'm
six three two hundred I'm going wait I'm
he's the golden bear he's supposed to be
like this big guy and he wasn't yeah
it's crazy you know I guess girl's kind
of always had this reputation of having
you know smaller guys you know most guys
are probably about six foot and maybe
weigh a hundred and eighty pounds
you know you look it if I stand next to
Justin Thomas I'm gonna look big yeah we
all do yeah so I mean God doesn't really
have many big big guys so when you when
I'm standing out there you know as a
normal probably normal sized guy looked
a little bit bigger but you put me next
to anybody you know I've stood next to
Steph Curry too on the range and I mean
he's a big dude like I mean I looked I
looked tiny next to those guys so it's
always quite funny when you get around
him
he's a Brooks captain of the PGA champ
what's your official height and weight
I'm like just under 6 1 and then I'm
weighing in at 208 just under yeah
you're desperate to get to 6 1 aren't
you yeah I'm trying and trying every day
trying to get there would you give up
the PGA Championship to be 6
- no okay if I if I had a bench off if I
say everybody on tour just bench who
wins oh good one I don't know I feel
like I'd be right up there I know that
I'm trying to think maybe Ernie back in
his day Ernie he's a strong guy
back in his day man I wouldn't I
wouldn't mess with Ernie what about Rory
he can throw some iron Rory
yeah maybe yeah I guess Rory yeah Rory
probably tough competition um yeah it'd
be interesting be fun though I'd love to
do it what's the worst job you've had oh
no I love that shirts off
you guys get in there and throw iron and
then I give how about winner gets a
hundred grand
perfect I'm in I'm sold all right that's
it maybe I can get tiger in there now
now that he's healthy
yeah okay back in the back in when he
was younger I'm sure he threw it around
and I mean he's a big dude what's the
worst job you had outside of golf being
a pro the worst job my stepmom owned a
pool safety fence company so we were
installing those in the middle of the
heat in Florida on summer I mean it was
a pain when you're like 15 16 years old
waking up at 6 o'clock in the morning I
mean not that wasn't fun anyways and
then they do that and to eat yeah that
was terrible and then you can't jump in
the pool yeah I mean you just cheese all
day homes and you're out there and the
pool is so nice and you're just out
there grinding away in the heat and
summertime with Florida and that's can
get quite hot I don't know and I hope
you appreciate where this is coming from
but do you want to be a star yeah I mean
I do I feel like I'm not I'm not used to
attention I'm not I'm not used to it yet
I don't feel like maybe I'm not the most
open person and to really let everyone
in I feel like I'm very kind of reserved
sometimes and that's how people can kind
of view it and you know they they view
my no real
- I'm just so focused into what I'm
doing you know I've got that I guess
game face in his own kind of attitude
and then you know sometimes you wish
people could see what goes on behind
closed doors they get like a snapshot of
your life from when you finish but you
know when I'm back there with my best
friend II flew in girlfriend my mom
everyone it's it's quite fun it really
is but I want it I want to be a star and
I feel like my game hopefully my game
does the talking there okay but help me
with this your mom was there off the
18th green when you walk off and I don't
know if you knew that she was gonna be
there I think you even said or she said
yeah we flew in today but your reaction
was hey how are you I that's that sounds
like somebody you just saw 15 minutes
earlier or you just came home from
school like I would have lost it if I
saw my mom there as I won the PG and
you're like hey how are you like okay
yeah that's the interesting reaction
it's one of those things where I mean I
had no idea she was there and then all
of a sudden I get surprised and I mean
what are you supposed to say I'm in this
moment of you know the happiest moment
of my life and then I look up and she's
there and I was sometimes you're just
speechless you don't know what to say
and you know my mom I love her to death
she's she's one of my best friends were
so close and I had no idea that she was
even going to be there and sometimes
just don't know what to say because she
was crying she was crying I'm like what
did you know what do you say like I'm
not the most emotional person you know
what people are crying and getting upset
and so happy and it's just kind of one
of those awkward look just got a laugh
at it now was she she used to work in TV
didn't she yes you did she used to work
for a TV channel down here so she was a
news anchor down here like she'd watch
mom on TV yeah and it was in yeah I get
to I get to watch her on TV when I was
little and you know the coolest part was
she'd actually never seen me win a golf
turn that's the first time in person
that's the first time in person she's
got to see me when i golfed her and
other than when I was like 12 years old
Brooks you just made it worse that's a
must cry situation mom is there she find
out I actually teared up I actually
teared up but people don't know I kind
of put my head down and kind of was like
all right I don't even know what to do
you know I whispered some things in her
years probably microphone couldn't even
pick up but it's it was it was really
cool it was really special what did you
major in in Florida State geography
believe it or not so I actually got to
experience that firsthand traveling
Europe and all that stuff and study in
all those places and then travel around
the world and actually visit and oh
that's cool pretty cool hey it was fun
and you know what if you display this
kind of personality to America Brooks
you'll become that star when you couple
what you do in majors how about you win
a regular event Brooks instead of just
these majors can you mix it up a little
bit I know I'm trying to win trying to
win these next couple weeks you know hey
I'm shooting for number one I'm trying
for it so hopefully these next few weeks
to go pretty well tweet out the picture
of the majors it'd be great to get that
from your kitchen counter and congrats
again Brooks you're good sport we
appreciate your time yep night Brooks
koepka
okay total transparency here I wasn't
sure what I was gonna get with Brooks
koepka now we'd been trying for months
he had won a couple majors I thought
after I picked him to win the US Open
and then he won all right maybe he would
join us
so Fritzi kept trying and then Fritzi
goes you still want Brooks koepka and I
went I don't I do but I don't know if
he's gonna be good he's gonna be fun and
then all of a sudden I'm halfway through
the interview and I'm going how could I
ever think that he wasn't gonna be fun
but it's based off of these other
interviews that I do but as he says you
kind of get locked in I got my game face
on that's a fun kid for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you
[Music]